I know I told you this last week, but once
again, the Dow Jones has crashed.
What is now another 2019 scene
record.
This time just over 800 points yesterday,
it wasn't just the Dow crashing more than
3%.
The Nasdaq fell more than 3%.
The S and p 500 fell more than 3% and it is
starting to get very, very ugly in real terms.
Uh, personally, although this doesn't matter,
I looked at my mutual fund account last night,
something I don't do that often and it was
ugly, very, very ugly.
I recommend, uh, most of you stay away from
those accounts if you have them as well.
But the economic implications are of course
much more important and drastic than the personal
implications.
And when we look at the effect or the non
effect of the federal funds rate cut that
we saw from the Federal Reserve, when we see
the continued impact of Donald Trump's trade
war, when we see continued instability in
the bond markets every, every day, we are
getting a little bit closer to us saying we
are now in a recession rather than getting
closer and closer to one and meanwhile, maybe
most disturbingly, because economic downturns
are part of the status quo.
But usually we want to feel good about the
person at the top, at least understanding
what's going on, if not necessarily being
able to do anything about it.
Trump, meanwhile is pretending like his economic
policies make sense that everything's fine,
uh, unless of course it isn't fine, in which
case it's definitely not his fault.
It's everybody else's fault.
It's Democrats, it's Obama, it's the Federal
Reserve because they didn't do a big enough
federal funds rate cut is trade war against
China.
Oh, that's very good.
That's definitely not the reason for economic
instability.
Farmers going out of business or anything
like that.
And Trump now personally attacking fed chairman
Jay Powell as clueless when it's of course
Donald Trump who has no idea what's going
on.
Take a look at this.
Trump saying, quote, we are winning big time
against China.
I mean that's just not true.
Companies and jobs are fleeing, they're fleeing.
The United States prices to us have not gone
up and in some cases have come down.
China is not our problem though.
Hong Kong is not helping.
Our problem is with the Fed raised too much
and too fast now to slow to cut.
Spread is way too much.
As other countries say thank you to clueless,
Jay Powell and the Federal Reserve, Germany
and many others are playing the game, crazy
inverted yield curve.
We should easily be reaping big rewards and
gains, but the Fed is holding us back.
We will win.
Even if you believed this story, which is
a completely story who nominated so-called
clueless Jay Powell to the Federal Reserve.
Oh, right.
It was Donald Trump himself.
But personal responsibility obviously not
happening, and this may actually be a real
problem for Trump.
Obviously a recession is a problem period.
And I don't want one, regardless of the political
implications that some Republicans are saying,
you left, these are hoping for a recession
to remove Trump.
No, we have more than enough evidence to remove
Trump to warrant removing Trump already.
Uh, we don't actually need a recession and
I'm not hoping for one, but remember that
Donald Trump's rich friends, we're all counting
on Trump at least boosting the stock market
so that they could make a ton of money while
lowering their tax rates.
The stock market is back down to where it
was about a year and a half ago, and they
could continue to look very ugly for the next
year, for the next many years.
Are Those Trumpists going to keep funneling
cash to Trump's campaign?
If Trump loses the stock market gains and
actually delivers losses, you almost can't
really even have an economic discussion during
the Trump administration because you have
a completely reckless, clueless, petulant
child with no understanding of economics or
trade policy or financial policy sort of feeling
around in the dark and making major policy
announcements via Twitter while blaming everyone
but himself for what's going on.
I want Donald Trump to lose in a landslide
in 2020.
I don't want it to happen because of a ruined
economy that's bad for everyone.
No matter what I want though it might be what
we end up with at the rate that things are
going.
And once again, we may end up with a terrible
stock market during a republican president,
a sensible recovery under the next democratic
administration, which Republicans will pretend
doesn't exist, followed by Republican saying
it was really Republicans that caused the
recovery rinse, repeat like Bush Obama.
And as we've seen many times in the past,
it doesn't look good and it is actually starting
to affect Donald Trump's approval rating.
Let's talk about that next